Thank you for that.
Happy Monday after Thanksgiving.
I hope you guys
had a good break.
We are back in action
here on acids and bases,
second lecture on
acid and bases.
Before we get into that,
there's a celebration
happening on Friday.
You know that's why
we're all feeling
like a little extra
goodness right now.
Because we know there's a
third midterm coming up Friday
in this class, right?
And that's nothing
but excitement.
Here's a concept map
that I made for exam 3.
This helps you sort of
see the kinds of problems,
right, that you could get,
the topics that we've covered,
and how it's all flowed and
connected together, all right?
So here are the quizzes.
There's the optional one.
Oh, you could still do it.
So please, if you want to do
the 8.5 and get that graded--
and then if it's higher
than your lowest quiz,
we'll swap it in for that.
And you still get to drop one--
please do that and hand it
in by tomorrow's recitation.
There's that one.
There's quiz-- there's
the other two quizzes.
And here are the psets,
and the goody bags.
All of this is the
kinds of problems--
this has the practice
problems and the topics
that we want you to
know about for Friday.
Oh, and also, on
Wednesday, instead
of introducing a new topic
that you won't be tested on,
I'd prefer just to talk
about these topics.
So that's what I'm going
to do on Wednesday.
And we'll do some additional
problems and kind of review.
OK, but we still got to get
through the rest of acids
and bases.
Now this is where we left off.
This way of thinking
about acids and bases
is where we left off on
Wednesday, all right?
And this is the
Arrhenius-- oh, Svante.
Oh, Svante-- he was
the first-- remember,
[INAUDIBLE] over thousands
of years would say,
this is bitter.
Put it in that category.
This is sour.
Mmm, right?
Acid-- no, base.
Acid.
And there are ways that people
categorized acids and bases
for a long time.
But nobody really started
to try to understand them
at the atomic scale until Svante
came along and said, look,
it's all about the H+
and the OH-, right?
So acids-- and this is what
we talked about on Wednesday.
Acids are donating H+ ions,
protons, into solution,
into water.
And bases are donating OH-,
adding more of those types
of ions into the water.
And that's what makes them have
the properties they have, OK?
Now, so if you have--
so let's see.
So H-- I'm going to just
write this one on the board.
Because we're going to talk
about these two reactions--
plus H2O--
and remember, the water is
just a kind of spectator there.
It's a liquid.
It's everywhere.
It's the thing
you're dissolving in.
It's the solvent.
That's the water.
So you don't include
it in these--
if it's just the liquid that
you're dissolving something,
it's not what you include
in things like equilibrium
constant expressions.
OK, so that's going to be--
oh, but these guys, these
are dissolved in the liquid,
all right?
These are the ions--
plus CL-.
OK, now in this
particular case, you
can write the equilibrium
constant, right?
And that's the acid.
It's also [INAUDIBLE] the
acid dissociation constant.
Remember, we had the
solubility product constant.
And we also can
write the Ka, right?
So Ka for this would be--
following our normal K
equilibrium constant procedure,
it would look something
like this, right?
Now here's the thing--
for this particular
reaction of--
for this particular dissociation
of HCl, of this acid--
and remember, it's an acid
because it's giving us H+.
Oh, H+ doesn't stay H+.
Remember, that's also what
we talked about Wednesday.
H+ is actually H3O+.
But the H+ is not
stable in pure water.
But sometimes-- actually,
very often-- you'll see it--
in textbooks as well-- you'll
see it just written as H+.
But we know that
it's the same thing.
H3O-- if it's in water, it's
H3O+, right, OK, so don't let--
but this is something
like 10 to the sixth.
That's huge.
That equilibrium is so far over.
That equilibrium is so far over
given this enormous equilibrium
constant, that we often will
say that this reaction has
gone to completion.
Now we know that
it's not infinite.
So it hasn't-- technically
there's still a little arrow
going that way, all right?
But-- and so, but since it's
so much almost to completion,
you'll often also see it written
with just one arrow, all right?
So I wanted to make that clear.
But we know that
it's an equilibrium.
This has found an equilibrium.
So there's still a little
bit happening the other way,
but just so little, all right?
So you'll often see that
going to completion.
OK, good-- getting us
back into the mood.
Now for the base,
we can have NaOH--
let's do that one--
plus H2O goes to Na+
in solution plus OH-.
And this is the Arrhenius
acid-base definition--
gesundheit.
And you could write a similar
expression for the base, Na+,
OH-.
And that's going
to go over NaOH.
Now this is also very large.
Now these are both strong.
And we're going to come back to
this at the end of the lecture.
I want to talk about what
makes an acid or a base
strong or weak.
These are both strong.
And just as a little preview
to where we're getting,
that's because they
dissociate so much.
So this also has
a very high Kb--
Kb, because we're
talking about a base--
Kb, Ka, Kb, right?
Oh, but some people don't
like these large exponents,
these large or small 10 to the
minus 5th, 10 to the positive
fifth.
And so we take the log.
You can take the log of these.
And then you'll get, like,
a pKb, right, or pKb,
which is the power of that.
So log of Kb would be
low, right, would be low.
If this is going
to be high, then
minus the log of the power
of that is going to be low.
So you can talk about
pKb, Kb, Ka, pKa.
It's all just thinking about
these equilibrium constants.
And we'll come back
to this in a second.
If I had a question for you--
if I said, OK, how
would you use this--
if I said that I've got point--
I'm going to give
you a problem now--
0.05 moles per liter of NaOH,
and I asked you, what's the pH,
well, you can do
it now, all right?
Why?
Because I've just told you
it's a almost fully dissociated
base.
So the equilibrium constant for
that dissociation of that base
is very, very high.
It means it lies very
far over to the right.
So basically, what
does that mean?
If I've got 0.05 moles
per liter starting out,
it's mostly dissociated.
[SNEEZE]
Gesundheit.
So I've got 0.05 moles per
liter of Na+ and OH-, all right?
OK, but the OH- is what matters.
So full dissociation-- oh, we're
going to do this because I want
to be precise here--
put that in quotes.
It's almost full-- means that
I have 0.05 moles per liter
of OH---
by the way, and Na+.
But Na+ is a spectator
in terms of the pH.
It's not going to change
the pH, right, the Na+?
Oh, but the OH will, all right?
And so now we go
back to these Ks.
We know-- right, we know--
that the equilibrium constant
of pure water is equal
to the concentration of H+
in solution, which is H3O+,
times OH-, and that that's
equal to 10 to the minus 14th,
all right?
That's another thing that we
talked about on Wednesday.
So if that's true, if the--
which it is at 25 C-- the
equilibrium constant for water,
which is--
remember, water
can be either one.
It's this times this.
And we know what this is.
Now you know what
that is, all right?
And if you know what H+--
if the concentration of
H+ is known, then the pH--
power of-- the p is
the minus lower--
the pH of that is something
you can calculate.
And so the pH winds up,
here, being 12.7, all rigth?
And that's the kind of thing
that you can have fun with.
You dissolve some base, and
you can measure a pH, or a pOH,
if you wanted--
all stuff we talked
about last week.
OK, but now we move on.
And now we're going to introduce
the next definition of acids
and bases by first talking about
what happens when you mix them
together, all right?
These are not
mixing together yet.
They're just-- a base
dissolves in water.
An acid dissolves in water.
But what if I had an acid and a
base, and I mix them together.
OK, well, so if I did that,
then I would have HCl plus NaOH.
Now I'm just going to--
I'm not going to
include the water.
It's there on the left, and it's
going to be there on the right.
I'm just going to write all
these ions down that happen,
right?
So you're going to get--
oh, you're going to get H+--
oh, we know it's H3O+--
plus Cl- plus Na+.
OK, these are all
dissolved in water.
I'm emphasizing that with the
little aqueous subscripts.
And you can see what's
going to happen now, right?
So if I have these there,
well, look at this.
The Na+ and the Cl-, boy, do--
they see each other,
and they're like, well,
maybe we could form some salt.
Maybe we could form some salt.
And then the OH and the
H, and those form water.
And so you can
get H2O plus NaCl.
And so what happens is
what's written there,
is that when you mix an acid
with a base, you will get water
and some salt.
Now remember, salt
is a general term, all right,
for these cations and anions,
right, coming
together in a solid.
So OK, now here's the
thing though, all right?
So this was the acid and
I'm writing this explicitly.
Because you'll see--
and this was the base.
Because what is neutralization?
Well, you think about
it in terms of pH.
I had something with maybe a
low pH, or maybe a high pH,
and I want it to become neutral.
Neutral would be--
if I'm in pure water,
Kw is 10 to the minus 14th.
Neutral would be-- it's the
same acid and base ratio.
So these are each 10 to
the minus seventh, pH 7,
neutral, all right?
There's no excess of
protons or OH-, all right?
So if there's no
excess, it's neutral.
So neutralization is basically
the act of making it neutral.
So I had something
that gave a lot of H+.
And now I got something
that gives me a lot of OH-.
If I have the same amount
of them, all right--
so they're equivalent-- then
you can make it neutral.
That's neutralization, OK?
But see, the thing
is I can take HCl,
and I can mix Windex,
or ammonia, with it
and neutralize it.
And back then, they
were like, but that
doesn't make any sense.
But first of all, because
we don't have Windex yet.
But second of all, because
Windex doesn't have any OH-.
Gesundheit.
And so that got them
really thinking, all right?
So if I take-- so
let's take NH3.
So if I take NH3--
dah.
If I take NH3 and I go
like this, NH3 plus HCl--
now this is not--
I'm not writing the liquid
dissociation of the thing.
I'm mixing it, acid
and something else
that I know neutralizes it.
And in fact, what
ends up happening
is you get-- gesundheit.
You get this.
And so what we know is
that this is neutralizing.
It's taking-- what's
happening in this reaction?
What's actually happening?
What did the--
what did that base
do effectively to
neutralize HCl?
What it did is it took
H+ from the solution.
That's what it did, all right?
So NH3-- in this
reaction, NH3 takes.
It takes H+ from the solution.
That's exactly-- HCl was like,
I want to make it acidic--
H+, H+, H+.
And NH3 is like,
no, give me the H+.
You cannot make this.
I'm neutralizing you.
I'm taking your H+ back.
If it takes that, then
that's neutralizing.
That's going to neutralize
the HCl as well.
But see, we have a problem.
Because this is not an
OH-donating molecule.
But it still neutralizes.
And so we need a broader
definition.
And that came from--
that came from
Bronsted and Lowry.
And so this is another
way of thinking,
a more general way of
thinking of acids and bases--
more general and more
correct, because the Arrhenius
definition does not cover
classes of molecules
that could be a base.
And so in this way, in the
Bronsted-Lowry definition--
in the Bronsted-Lowry
definition--
it's all about the proton.
So let me write that down here.
So in Bronstein and Lowry,
their definition is that acid--
and he did it by looking
at acid-base neutralization
reactions like I just described.
Acid-base neutralization--
I'm not going to write it,
because there's no room--
reactions is all about
the proton transfer.
These are proton
transfer reactions.
This is how they saw acids and
bases, as exchanging a proton.
Taking it or giving it, that's
what it's about, all right?
And so in our sort of general--
you know, in the general HA
lingo that we introduced,
you would have HA plus B. And
that's going to go to BH+ plus
A-.
That's an acid-base reaction.
And so you can see that these
are-- this is a proton donor.
This is a proton donor.
And this is an acceptor.
It's a donor, H+
donor, H+ acceptor.
That defines them, according
to Bronsted and Lowry,
as acids and bases.
OK.
OK, well we can also--
OK, so now let's see.
Let's now go back.
That's a broader definition.
Let's now go back
to the ammonia, OK?
And what I want to do now
is, instead of mixing it
with an acid to think about
whether it trades a proton,
I want to just
dissolve it in water.
So now we know it's a base, OK?
So what happens?
So if I dissolve NH3 in H2O--
I want to point something
out here, that if I do this,
and I get NH4+ plus
OH-, that's the--
now I'm taking a base.
So there we had--
there's the acid.
Here's the base.
That's the Arrhenius base.
But now I'm taking a
Bronsted-Lowry base, right?
It took an H+.
Well, that means
that this is a base.
But look, this-- OK,
this gave a proton.
So this must be an acid
according to Bronsted--
according to Bronsted and Lowry.
And similarly,
over here, we know
that this is going to give one.
And I'm going to write
that in a second.
And this would
love to accept one.
So that's a base, right?
And remember, we
have a name for this.
In the same reaction,
we have a name for this.
This would be the
conjugate, all right?
Those are conjugates.
That's why I'm writing
those, all right?
So there's a conjugate
base-acid, conjugate acid-base.
Now we have a
Bronsted-Lowry understanding
of what conjugate
acid-base means.
It's just a proton
transfer, all right?
It's just a proton transfer.
Now notice I could take this--
so I've taken this base,
and I've put it into
a solution of water.
I could take this acid
and do the same thing.
So if I do that, I've got NH4+.
And I'm going to put
that in water now, OK?
So I've taken this out.
And now I'm putting
that acid into water.
And if I do that,
look at what happens.
I get NH3 plus H3O+.
Notice what happened.
Well, I've switched acid.
That's my acid.
But this took the proton,
so it must be a base, right?
And over here I've got the base.
And this must be an acid.
Proton transfer, that's
what's happening here--
conjugates.
I took the base,
and I got an acid.
So this tells us that water--
and it tells us what
we said on Wednesday.
Water can be both.
Notice water is an
acid in the one hand
and a base on the other.
That makes it amphoteric.
So H2O can be both.
It can take or give protons.
And so it is amphoteric.
Just for fun, if you take
the conjugate-- you know,
if you take any acid-base
pair, and they're conjugates,
you can also write out the
Ka's and Kb's, all right?
And so if I take a
conjugate acid and base,
well, you know that you
could write Ka, all right?
OK, so let's write the
acid dissociation again.
So for that one, here it is.
Ka is NH-- is H3O+.
OK, I'm going to take the bottom
one, H3O+, times NH3, right,
concentrations, divided by NH4+.
But if I took the
base dissociation
constant from the conjugate--
I'm taking the
conjugates now, right--
then I would get that it's--
OK, it's OH- and
NH4+ divided by NH3.
Like I'm saying, just for
fun, you can now look at this.
You go, Ka times Kb--
Ka times Kb.
That's reassuring that Ka times
Kb is equal to H3O+ times OH-.
And I mean concentrations,
which is Kw.
That is fun, for the
Bronsted-Lowry acid-base
conjugate.
NH4+, NH3, right?
OK.
OK, that's Bronsted-Lowry
Lowry acids and bases.
Here's a little recap.
I'm not going to read
through this in detail,
but I just wanted to give you--
OK, what have we done so far?
We've talked about amphoteric.
We've talked about
conjugate acids and bases.
These are now written in the
Bronsted-Lowry form, right?
They accept or give a proton.
We've talked about the conjugate
acid-base pair, what I just
drew an example of right
there, neutralization
reactions, and salt. OK, good.
These are some concepts
that we have covered that I
would like you to know about.
Now but there's a
few more concepts
that we have to come back to--
a few more concepts that
we have to come back to.
And it has to do with
what I started with.
In the beginning, I said,
you know, these Ks are huge.
So the equilibrium-- if an
equilibrium constant lies--
is very large, then you know
you're mostly making product,
right?
And so it's essentially
to completion.
And I also mentioned
that those are strong,
strong acids, strong bases--
strong acids, strong bases.
Why is an acid or
base strong or weak?
That's what I want to talk
about next, all right?
And actually, there are--
there really aren't that many
strong acids or strong bases.
In fact, they're mostly here.
These are really, pretty
much most of them.
Minor [INAUDIBLE] I
don't want to go into.
But these are really--
if you think about the general
category of strong acids,
strong bases, this is it.
Why?
Why is that?
Well, it has to do with what
we've been talking about,
all right?
So those are strong acids.
Those are strong bases.
It has to do with dissociation.
So if I take HCl and
I put it in water,
it almost completely
dissociates.
That's why it's a strong acid.
Now there's confusion
around this.
And I want to make that--
I want to make it very clear.
There is a big distinction
I want to make.
Because if something
is a weak acid,
meaning it's not one of
these, what that means is it
doesn't dissociate very much.
That's what it means.
It doesn't have anything to do
with concentration, all right?
So let's take a weak acid.
Let's take vinegar, all right?
So if I take a weak acid--
we see vinegar as CH3COOH.
You know what's nice about
writing them out this way?
You say, why didn't
you put the H in there,
and make it CH4, and CO2,
or put the two Cs together?
Oftentimes you'll see
molecules written out this way,
because this tells
us a little bit
of a hint about connectivity.
And for acids and bases,
it's actually useful.
Because you see the H there?
That's the one that's
going to trade.
That's the Bronsted-Lowry
transfer H, all right?
So often, for acids
and bases, you'll
see that written
out in this way.
Makes it easier to think about.
And if I mix this into
water, then what do I get?
Well, I'm going to get H3O--
I'm going to write
this down here--
H3O+-- that's an acid, right--
plus CH3COO-.
There's the H that came off--
proton transfer.
So why is it weak?
Well, it's weak because here,
the acid equilibrium constant
is something like 10
to the minus fifth.
So even if I have a lot, you do
even if I had like 1 mole per
liter of this stuff in
solution, it wouldn't--
most of it wouldn't dissolve.
In fact, much less than a
percent of vinegar actually
gives me H3O+, all right?
But you think, oh,
just add more vinegar.
No.
No, because we're talking
about concentrations, right?
It's the concentration
in that water.
I'm locked into that by this.
This is an equilibrium constant.
And it's talking about
the concentration
that I get in the water.
I'm stuck.
I can't be-- that's how
much you dissociate, right?
That's how much you
associate as a concentration.
So it's more acidic than
water for sure, all right?
It's 100 times more acidic
than water, all right,
10 to the minus fifth.
But it's never going to be a
strong acid, because I don't
give very much of the protons.
So this is the key that
I want to make clear.
This is the key, OK?
It's very important.
It gets its own board.
The strength of an acid, OK?
So acid concentration is
not equal to acid strength.
More, and more, and
more vinegar-- no.
It doesn't matter, because
it's about association.
See, this is about--
this is a function
of the solubility.
So how much can I get in there?
We talked about all
that a lot already.
That's a different thing,
solubility, the Ksp.
How much of this can I dissolve?
Great.
I can dissolve a lot
of vinegar in water.
And it doesn't crash out, right?
That's wonderful.
Doesn't make it a strong acid.
This is about
dissociation, all right?
And so if you think about what
makes an acid a strong acid--
or for that-- or a weak acid,
or what the relative strengths
of acids are-- and the
same holds for bases,
just the other way around--
it has to do with how easy it
is to take that H off or add it
on, right?
That's what it has to do with.
And so if you look
at-- for example,
if you look at just a
little series, all right--
if you look at a series
there, even the strong acids
have differences.
They're all strong.
They go mostly to completion.
But if you think about it
in terms of what we just
talked about, the
acid strength is
going to go roughly
often opposite trend
as bond strength.
That's of the proton
transfer of the H, all right?
There is an H--
HCl, HBr, HI.
Which will be the strongest
acid of those three, right?
Well, we now know.
This must be the
strongest, right?
Opposite-- because this
is going to be easier
to get the hydrogens
off in solution.
And you can think about the weak
acids in the same exact way.
These are the strong acids.
This holds for all--
you know, it's a
proton transfer.
It's all about the
strength of the proton.
Neutralization is
a proton transfer.
Whether you make an acid
strong or how strong it is
depends on how many of those
protons go into solution.
And so you can look
up charts like this.
And I love looking
at this stuff,
because it makes you think
about the chemistry, all right?
So here you go.
You've got, OK, acid, different
acids, molecular formula,
all right, structural
formula, conjugate--
notice they're putting
that H there in blue.
Oh, that's so helpful.
And you just look at the blue
H, and you think about it
as dissociating, just like
Bronsten and Lowry did.
You think about
that as coming off.
And then you think about the
conjugate base, all right,
that's formed on the other side.
And then you go
over here, and you
think, oh, this tells me how
much it's coming up, how often.
This tells me the equilibrium
of putting this into solution.
You say, this is--
which one of these is going
to be weaker or stronger,
all right?
Well, and what does that mean
about the bond strength itself?
What does that mean about
how easy it is to dissociate?
We now know.
And we can think about
that, and understand that.
These are not-- these
may look similar,
these Hs attached to carbon or
oxygen. What's the difference?
Big difference when
you put them in water.
A lot more or a lot
less might come off.
Changing the acid strength--
the more that comes off,
the more the dissociation
is to the right, all right?
Oh, and the lower,
right, the higher
this number, because
the equilibrium moves
over to the right, all right?
And the less that comes off, the
lower this equilibrium constant
is, Ka, right--
the lower it is.
The higher the pK--
we don't like these
small, tiny numbers.
You take a minus log,
and you talk about pKs.
That's fine, all right?
OK, good.
This is the kind of
fundamental understanding
of acids and bases that
I want you guys to have.
And so if we go back
to neutralization,
now you say, well, OK,
this makes sense, right?
We had a strong acid
and a strong base.
If you had them equivalent,
you'd get a pH of 7.
Now you know, if you had
a strong acid, weak base,
weak acid, strong
base, it's going to--
this is fairly self-explanatory,
less than 7 or greater than 7.
And now you know also, if it's
a weak acid and a weak base,
and you're neutralizing
these together,
it would depend
on the Ka and Kb.
Because it depends on
how many of those ions
you put in solution
or can take out.
And that's given by
the Ka and Kb, OK?
Good.
So we could answer
questions-- we're now
armed to answer questions.
And like I said,
I want to answer--
we're going to do some
problems on Wednesday.
We'll talk about the topics
that are going to be on exam 3.
But we can answer
questions like this.
Here we are talking
about acids and bases.
What if I mix a bunch
of them together,
and they've got different Ka's?
So think about this, what if
I mix all of these together?
Can I get my pH, right?
So here's a question.
You have 1 mole per liter
of HCN with that acid
dissociation constant and
5 moles per liter of HNO2
with that one.
What's-- OK, you write
that dissociation reactions
and calculate the
pH of the solution.
That's a good question, right?
So let's see.
Now how would I answer it?
Well, oh, Bronsted-Lowry,
don't want to erase you,
but I have to.
I have no choice.
So let's answer that question.
The way that we
think about this,
it's telling us what to do.
Write the dissociation
reactions for each species.
OK, so I'm going
to write it down.
So I have HCN.
HCN, right, is going
to go to H+ plus CN-.
Now Ka, for this,
is equal to H+--
oh boy, did I drop
my subscripts-- times
CN- divided by HCN
concentrations.
But we're back to solubility
product days, right?
This is an equilibrium.
And so it's going both ways.
But you know from the
coefficients here--
all right, you know
from those coefficients
that if I dissociate x amount
of this, then that's how much
of this and this that
I make, all right?
So now I know, right, that--
well, OK-- Ka times--
if I just bring
this over there--
HCN is equal to x
squared, where x--
let's let x equal
concentration of H+,
which equals the
concentration of CN-.
Been there, done that, right,
from the solubility product
problems that we've done.
And so you can get, from this,
that the concentration of H+,
which is also H3O+, is equal
to 2.5 times 10 to the minus 5
moles per liter.
Good.
OK.
But you can keep going.
And I'm not going
to do all the math.
But you could go through
the same exercise with HNO2.
So for HNO2, you get
that the concentration
of these ions that you
get from that dissociation
is around 2 times 10 to the
minus 3 moles per liter.
And by the way, maybe
I got less than 10
to the minus seventh
out of these things--
maybe.
Maybe if I did, then,
if I did, then I'd
also need to take into
account pure water, right?
So from pure water, we know, if
you just had water by itself,
then you'd have,
the concentration
here is 10 to the minus
seventh moles per liter.
But now you just look
at this, and you say,
OK, I got my answer.
Because everything's a lot
lower than this one thing.
So this is going to dominate.
I mix it all together.
But you see, it doesn't matter.
The other things aren't able to
disassociate nearly as many H+
ions--
they're just not able to--
as HNO2.
So this dominates.
And you can just calculate
the pH from this.
So you're going to get,
like, two, three digits down
some effect.
But it's OK, right?
From this, you can get the pH.
And the pH is equal to 1.35.
The total contribution of
H+ ions in that solution is
roughly given by this
contribution here, OK?
Might not have been,
but it was in that case.
OK, how about this one?
So here's another-- OK, so we
could take another example.
Let's stay over here.
OK, so in this example,
I'm barely giving you
anything here, it seems like.
But I give you enough.
I've got a 0.2 moles per
liter solution of a weak acid.
And it's 9.4% dissociated.
That's the key.
Because remember, this
is-- now we've learned
the Bronsted-Lowry definition.
It's all about H+
in or coming out.
That's what-- there it is.
Now I erase it though.
It's all about the H+.
So if I know 9.4%
dissociated, I know something
about what kind of
acid that is, right?
So if I have, now, HA plus
H2O, and that goes to H3O+--
I've switched back-- plus A-,
then how much dissociated?
Well, 0.2 moles per
liter times 0.094, right?
So 0.094, that's the percent--
is that right?
Yes, 9.4%-- times
0.2 moles per liter.
And that equals
0.019-ish, right?
That's how much HA--
HA-- dissociated.
But if I know that,
and I know my reaction,
and I got the stoichiometric
coefficients from the reaction,
then I also know how
much H3O+ and A- formed.
If that much dissociated,
then that much formed, right?
Because they're-- right?
That's the reaction.
Those are the coefficients.
And so I can get it all.
And I can calculate Ka, which
equals 2 times 10 to the minus
third.
I didn't give the pH.
All I gave you was how
much of it dissociated.
I didn't even tell
you what acid it was.
But that's OK, because we now
know that this is what counts.
This dissociation, how
many of these Hs per liter,
how many of those go into
solution is what matters.
OK, now there's another thing
that I want to talk about.
And we'll do some more--
you know, a little
bit more, like I
said, problems on Wednesday.
There's just one more thing
I want you to know about
related to acids
and bases, and that
is that you can
have more than one.
All these examples, if
you go back to this list,
those all had one hydrogen
that was ever going to leave,
let's say.
I mean, OK, ever--
maybe if you went up
to the middle of the sun or
something, you'd get those.
But this is-- you know,
in normal conditions,
these are the ones that are
going to leave, and no more.
But you can have molecules
like phosphoric acid where--
look at all those protons.
So here's acetic acid.
That's the one that's
willing to leave.
Those are not.
They're on the carbon.
Way too hard to get them off.
This one-- OK, in solution,
sure, to a certain extent.
In phosphoric acid, I've
got three hydrogens.
And so that's called
a multiprotic acid.
Why?
Because protic-- proton--
how many protons, right?
It could be monoprotic, like
the ones we've talked about,
or it could be multiprotic,
like phosphoric acid.
And so if you think
about this the way
we now think about
acids and bases,
we think about an acid
as a dissociation, right,
with some dissociation
equilibrium constant.
And so if you think about
phosphoric acid, H3PO4--
oh, let's put the
water in, H2O, liquid.
And that goes to
H2PO4- plus H3O+.
Well the Ka for this one is--
so if I put the Ka's
in here, this one
is 7.5 times 10 to the minus 3.
But see, what happens
is, now, this one
has two more hydrogens
that could come off.
So you could write those
dissociation reactions as well.
So H2PO4-, if you put that
in solution, which it is,
then that could give
you HPO4 2-, all right?
H2, H-- it's a proton transfer.
Minus, 2-, all right--
plus H3O+.
And there's one
more, plus one more.
This dissociation constant
is much, much smaller,
6.2 times 10 to the minus 8.
And the third one is 4.2
times 10 to the minus 13th.
So they're smaller,
but they happen.
And that's important.
And it can be very important.
It depends on the molecule.
But in this case, it's not just
the parent, that acid there
that's losing a proton.
But then, this one can
also lose a proton.
It can also be an acid.
It just has an equilibrium
that's not as far over.
So it's not going to give as
many H+ into solution, OK?
It's important to know about.
Then finally, the last
thing I want you to know,
you will not be tested on
this, but it's important.
Because here's where we are.
Here's where we are.
Arrhenius said, right
before Thanksgiving,
it's all about the
H+ and the OH-.
That got us really far, got
us through Thanksgiving.
But then today, we're like, no,
it's got to be more general.
It's just proton transfer.
No, don't tell me about OH-.
And so then comes Lewis.
Oh, we know Lewis.
We've already talked
a lot about Lewis.
Lewis said, why are you guys
all obsessed about protons?
And he said it in just that way.
An acid is much more
general even than that.
An acid is any
species, anything that
except a pair of electrons.
Remember, Lewis was all about
those electrons and the octets.
And a base is any species that
can donate a pair of electrons.
So Lewis correctly took
a much more general view
and said, no, acids
and bases are not
even about proton transfer.
They're about electron transfer.
And again, I'm not going to test
you on Lewis, acids, and bases,
but I wanted you to
have that full picture.
That means, by the
way, aluminum 3+--
take an aluminum
atom, make it 3+.
It wants electrons.
It's an acid.
It's an acid, all right?
Doesn't have a prot-- it
wants electrons though.
That makes it an acid
according to Lewis.
So that concludes
acids and bases.
And I'll see you
guys on Wednesday.